[Music]
you know that really really tall girl
that you go to school with would you
maybe wanna well that's me
16 years old six foot one and a half
while how's the weather up there nice
sweat pants sasquatch
what'd you say to my best friend Farida
please honey you just have to be strong
in the face of adversity oh I love it
that's the one you're perfect I just
think it's crazy you won't date a short
guy do you really think that at any
moment so holler than you perfect guy is
just gonna walk through that door okay
I'm going
you are
[Music]
no of course I'm not yeah I got out of
customs what an hour ago and she's
already marking her territory and I can
America so far I'm lucky America very
much
one day Jodee you're gonna stand up and
say I love all 73 inches of myself I was
hoping you'd wanna go with me to the
homecoming test yeah yeah sure sure I
mean gotcha let's face it Jodi here the
tall girl I just want you to feel done
every time you try to make me feel more
normal you just end up making me feel
like more of a freak all right I need
your help little sister I've been
waiting for this day to come my entire
life
I'm going to extreme makeover the crap
out of you let's get to work
you should so you're telling me that I
look Austin lip glass or stop stressing
I look like grandma's couch or a
beautiful mermaid princess now this is
me I like new Jodi face your fears Jodi
going after what you want Jodi
I've been in love with this girl since
elementary school this new guy slows up
my plan
you're moving in on my man no not stay
away from it I will stop agreeing with
everything I'm saying okay oh we've all
got something about ourselves we wish we
could change you're not big little
sister that's me the only thing that we
can control is how we deal with it when
you're a tall girl it's it's the only
thing that people see it's not the only
thing I see I just want to make sure
that you don't get hurt
[Music]